مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
نفاق
[موسيقى]
الهلال قدم عرض خزعبلي خرافي لكليان مبابي
332 مليون دولار قيمه الصفقه او قيمه
الانتقال
ويقال بتقارير صحفيه انه الراتب يمكن يوصل
لفوق ال75 مليون دولار ارقام خياليه ما
كنا نتخيل انه ممكن تصير بعالم كره القدم
ولكن الدوري السعودي حاليا عم بيقدم ارقام
جديده وعم ياخذ سوق الانتقالات بعلم كره
القدم الى ليفل مختلف او الى مستوى اخر
تماما الموضوع انه صندوق الاستثمارات مثل
ما حكينا استحوذ على الانديه السعوديه او
على اربعه انديه سعوديه وبلش يعمل صفقات
كبيره ابتداء من صفقه بنزيما وانتهاء الان
بتقديم العرض لكيليان مبابي طيب شو الامور
او شو التفاصيل المعطيات اللي راح تخلي
باب ينتقل للهلال او ما ينتقل للهلال براي
الشخص العامل الاول والاهم والرئيسي هو
موضوع المده مده العقد يعني الهلال اذا
قدم عرض لمده موسم واحد على سبيل المثال
فهو عمليا عم بيكون وسيله لانتقال كيليان
مبابي من باريس سان جيرمان لريال مدريد
مجانا الموسم المقبل باقي حاليا بورطه
كبيره لحتى نفهم الوضع لانه اللاعب برا
السكواد تبع بي اس جي مثل ما عرفنا
الاسبوع الماضي النادي اصلا ما اخذوا معه
على اليابان بعد ما رفض تجديد العقد او
تمديده لمده اضافيه او لعام 2025
وقال له لازم تروح تدور لك على نادي وترحل
ولحد الان ما في انديه جديه قدمت عروض
يعني بمستوى عرض الهلال او حتى ربع ارض
الهلال لكن عم نسمع عن انديه يعني ما
عندها القدره اساسا انه تتعاقد مع كيليان
مثل برشلونه ومثل انتر وتوتنهام وغيرهم من
الانديه اللي اصلا قدرتهم الماليه ما
بتساعدهم ابدا على انهم يتعاقدوا مع
اللاعب بمبلغ لا كبير ولا صغير حتى ولا
يدفعوا راتبه فعمليا كيليان مبابي الان
امام خيارين ايام ما عم يستنى ريال مدريد
يدفعوا له
المبلغ معين 150 ولا 160 مليون دولار
مقابل انتقال لصفوف الموسم المقبل او انه
يضطر انه يجدد مع باريس سان جيرمان لموسم
اضافي ويستنى الفرج الموسم الجاي هل ريال
مدريد راح يدفع ولا ما راح يدفع اجاء عرض
الهلال ليكون بمثابه الانقاذ لذلك موقف
الهلال بهذا العرض افضل من موقف مبابي
ولكن الهلال اذا قدم عرض لمده موسم واحد
فهل هذا الامر راح يخدم مصلحته وجود مبابي
بالدوري السعودي لموسم واحد فقط هل هو
كافي عن جد انه يجيب التاثير اللازم ان
كان
ولا ان كان ببيع القمصان والان كان
بمتابعه المباريات هل فعلا رح يخدم رؤيه
السعوديه بانه تحول الدوري تبعها لواحد من
الدوريات العشره الكبرى بالعالم هل فعلا
راح يزيد الايرادات بالدرجه الكافيه بموسم
واحد فقط شخصيا لا اعتقد انه راح يكون له
تاثير كبير اكيد راح يكون في تاثير ولكن
مش التاثير النوعي للهلال طالبه من هاي
الصفقه لذلك طالما انه التاثير مش كبير
فتقديم عرض لمده موسم واحد مش بمصلحه
الهلال مصلحه الهلال انه يقدم عرض لمده
موسمين على الاقل لانه عمليا لما انت
بتطلع سمعه على مثلا الهلال او الكره
السعوديه ان هي انه هي وسيله كانت
الانتقال امبابه من بي اس جي لريال مدريد
هذا امر ما بخدمات ولا بيخدم رؤيتك اساسا
لذلك انت محتاج اللاعب يكون عندك لمده
موسمين على الاقل تستفيد منه الاستفاده
الكافيه وبعدين تمشي موضوع الموسمين هذا
ما بيخدم مصلحه كيليان مبابي لانه عمليا
مبابل بده ينتقل على ريال مدريد وريال
مدريد بده اللاعب مجانا وبالتالي الحل
الامثل بالنسبه له عرض لمده موسم واحد مع
الهلال روح اخذ لي 700 مليون واحمل حالي
واتكل على الله على ريال مدريد مجانا
الموسم المقبل ومع السلامه خلص نحقق
اهدافنا وطموحاتنا باوروبا موضوع انتقال
مبابي للسعوديه حاليا مختلف عن بنزيما
مختلف عن مختلف عن بقيه اللاعبين لانهم
مبابي لحد الان 23 سنه او 24 سنه
ما جاب دوري الابطال ما جاب الكره الذهبيه
وهي من اهدافها الرئيسيه وبالتالي انه
يروح على السعوديه بالوقت الراهن فهذا امر
غير مطروح الا اذا كان في شيء عن جد ضروري
ولا يمكن الا انه يكون هو الخيار الوحيد
فمنطقيا الشيء الوحيد اللي ممكن يغري
كيليان مبابي بالانتقال الى الهلال عم
نحكي منطقيا هو موضوع المبلغ الكبير
المقدم بمقابل انه ما يستغني او ما يتخلى
عن احلامه اللي موجوده باوروبا موقف ريال
مدريد من كل هذا الحكي انه ناطر وعم يستنى
بس عم يتفرج على عم يستنى لانه عمليا ريال
مدريد عم يكسب وقت عم بيلعب على الوقت
بحيث انه كل ما قربنا من الموسم المقبل
سعر كيليان مبابي راح ينزل لانه الضغط على
بي اس جي راح يزيد اتحاد العمال الفرنسي
اعتقد عمل هجمه شرسه على بي اس جي بسبب
كيليان مبابي وقال انه ما بصير تعامل
موظفك بهذه الطريقه ولازم تامن له دائما
ظروف العمل الملائمه لحتى يكون مرتاح
بالوظيفه اللي هو فيها وما بصير تعجله
بالطريقه اللي بي
على اداره ناصر الخليفي بنفس الوقت
المشكله عم تتعمق فهو مراهن انه مع الوقت
سعر كيليان مبابي مع اقتراب نهايه السوق
راح يقل وبالتالي راح يلاقي حالهم مضطر
انه يبيع اللاعب هاي المغامره مغامره
محفوفه بالمخاطر بالنسبه لريال مدريد لانه
يمكن كثير بنهايه الامر كيليان مبابي يقول
لك انتم ما قدمت عرض وما اجاني عرض مناسب
وانا بدي اظل باوروبا فتلاقيه بجنب مع
باريس سان جيرمان لموسم 2025 وريال مدريد
الموسم المقبل او اللي بعده يضطر يدفع
مبلغ كبير للتعاقد مع كيليان مبابي وما
يستفيد شيء من الانتظار الا انه ضيع عليه
سوق انتقالات اخر مثل ما ضيع سوق
الانتقالات الماضي وضيع عليها لاند بس من
شان كيليان مبابي وبالنهايه ما ربح شي
فمنطقيا موضوع المده هو العامل الرئيسي
بهذا الموضوع كلياته حاليا بموقف صعب جدا
هو مش عارف مستقبله وين رايح متورط مش
عارف شو يسوي يجدد مع بي اس جي ولا يروح
على ريال ولا يروح على ولا يستنى عرض اخر
لحد الان الامور مش مبينه في تشتت واضح
بموقف كيليان مبابي وهو اللي بموقف ضعف
بمقابل انه الهلال اذا اجا مبابي فاهلا
وسهلا ما اجى حسب مش مشكله عادي بنجيب
غيره في كثير لاعبين اخرين ممكن نجيبهم عن
الفريق باسعار اقل
وبمردود اكبر على مدار السنوات المقبله
فرضيه انتقال مبابي بعد موسم لنيوكاسل هاي
فرضيه مضحكه جدا وبتترافق مع اي صفقه على
الدوري السعودي مثل ما شفنا مع كريستيانو
رونالدو وغيره لانه انتقال اي لاعب
لنيوكاسل حتى لو نيوكاسل تابع لصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه السعودي بيختلف عن
رؤيه السعوديه للدوري السعودي المحلي
بيختلف عن اهداف السعوديه من استقطاب
اللاعبين الكبار للدوري السعودي نيوكاسل
مشروع تحت مظله صندوق الاستثمارات مثل
مشروع الدوله السعودي ولكن مشروع منفصل
تماما عن مشروع الدوري السعودي ولا اعتقد
انه بيلتقوا بكثير محلات
بنهايه الامر نحن امام موقف لاعب مثل ما
حكينا متورط فريق مقدم عرض بمبلغ كثير
كبير واعتقد انه ورط ايضا ريال مدريد لانه
بي اس جي الان صار بموقف افضل شوي مع عرض
الهلال انه اوكي عنا عرض موجود للاعب
فانتو لازم تحصلوا عرضكم يا ريال مدريد
والا راح نبيعه للهلال ويقال مثل ما قالوا
بي اس جي تقريبا موافقين على عرض الهلال
عنا ريال مدريد ومستني المجهول وبحاول
يراهن على الوقت لحتى ينزل صفقه كيليان
مبابي وعنا فرق اخرى يعني عم تلعب على ما
يبدو عم بتقدم عروض اعتقد انه راح تكون
اقل ما يقال عنا ان مضحكه للتعاقد مع
كيليان مبابي على مدار الاشهر المقبله على
شو راح تخلص هاي القصه كلياتها اعتقد انه
هذا امر رهن الوقت ولكن ريال مدريد عم
يشتغل على فرضيه انه ينبات اليوم بفلوس
بكره يبقى ببلاش هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه لون
بعض الصافي حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل
يكونوا بالف خير